enough like a pineapple we here's
another thing but because of those shots
yeah you were married
mm-hmm but that I don't talk about oh
you don't talk about your death no your
wife no too personal Wow too painful you
know how that yeah yeah you know how
yeah you know what's so funny that I'm
not gonna explore it further thank you
you're welcome you're very welcome
better very thank you what'd I say what
I wanted to say is that was the first
time and I think we're getting somewhere
in our relationship that was the first
time that you I when you said I don't
want to talk about it because you and I
when we're at the Comedy Store what do
we like we just joke around yeah we [ __ ]
around always free for a year you called
me Sarah Silverman what what yeah he
would not call me by my regular he goes
he'll go oh it's Sarah Silverman right
and everyone would laugh and but he did
it every time I saw him for years
well no first I called you a shy guy
yeah yeah and then went to Sarah
Silverman yeah and then now what is that
now we just giggle and I got called you
Carol Leifer
it's always something right so har
Lynette and I have that kind of
relationship right I'll call him so I
don't know what I call him but um and we
goof off and this and that and in my
head I'm like I like this guy I want to
be his friend
you know he invited us to that fourth of
July thing that was really nice rosie
was there you know we're four good
friends with Rosie's we've done this a
couple of times is podcast and um and I
could you know I could really become
your friend you know for real but that
was the first time that you did
something that was so real and I got it
just now when you said I don't wanna
talk about it
yeah so weird that there's more of that
where that came from guy well there's a
lot of things you don't want to talk
about you know it just to ask your
dreams are about to come true guy yeah
[Music]
let me ask you this though you have a
girlfriend now no you don't want to talk
about anything like that no I can talk
about that I wish I did
especially when I see you know people
with beautiful girlfriends and
boyfriends it's nice do you think I'm
beautiful
no thank you no I do yeah
I think you have a beautiful spirit you
bring a lot of joy to people a beautiful
spirit speaking of beautiful spirits um
somebody died over the weekend oh god it
wasn't Prince was it please don't bring
this on me it wasn't them thank God it
wasn't them riced sandy shore died so
Pauly's our sister died oh I didn't know
her why and his mother just died
yeah how did she die she was young she
had like a long thing existing so she
was sick for a year and she had a long
thing and it's like it's it's you know
it's just it's really just kind of sad
because she she she didn't uh she owed
me money very classy of you kidding she
did okay there it is the Western Union
maybe you're in the will bro no I'm not
you know but I feel bad I know I laughed
at it I you know anyone listening right
now I'm
evil I really did I do care and it's
really sad that what happened and I use
comedy and laughter as a defense
mechanism but you know life is precious
and I love the shores and I love the
Comedy Store and this is a really bad
thing that happened you know and the
money thing is it's fine you know
I don't deal with death good do you know
you advertise funeral at there I was not
at the memorial the memorial you know
what to the memorial right yeah I didn't
know her very well I only met her once
all one time yeah years ago you know
when I first moved to Hollywood yeah I
did a showcase for and then did she pass
you I didn't even know there was passing
I just thought you wanted to watch
people I just you know to me I'd give me
a microphone and a crowd that's all I
asked for if you were always a Laugh
Factory guy right I mean I mean yeah I
feel whenever a lot yeah even when I was
moving up here from San Diego you would
say who are the Laugh Factory guy he
would Marlon Williams um Bob Marley
Marley you just do shows with Bob Marley
right yeah gain was over there and that
was the laugh acted crew really yeah and
so when when you came over the the could
I know you still play the laugh at you
but when you came over the comedy stove
it was a really cool [ __ ] thing man
because we eat just in my lifetime I
never thought that we would get guys
like Harlan to come over you know it's
been really fun I've been doing it for
about a year
you loved you you do seriously love the
store now really yeah yeah it doesn't
matter I like iced a microphone and a
crowd right but I don't you know I love
I love the store I love the laughs I
love but I just I love the crowd that's
who I love yeah but just you fit in that
room though I do yeah you do okay I like
it yeah it's amazing yeah
yeah man party excuse me
I said party I heard you I heard that
you said that
[Music]